[Music]
you're a little jammed
your mind's a little tight
okay and you need the thumb on your
chest not her knuckles and then you
overpower her
again not the face of her necklace
[Music]
okay
now there's your hand
you can look at it look at it you can
you see it's already in place so if i
could i would put my hand in my chest
but it's going to compromise other
things okay
so
you're going to get up
that's why you're
you're overpowering my
elbow hand of each other okay
and your hands already in place
so i'm not going to let you up
go it starts to turn
do you see and i end up like that and
then you go like this
that's
overpowering what i want to do is figure
out
how to get this to here without doing
anything to it
okay so you start to compromise the
elbow hand and i just move one more tank
on and it's right in place
and you're coming around and you put
yourself into it
you see
[Music]
so there's that same taoist principle
of wu way
coming in
you start to compromise elbow don't
shove down on it
let it go
take one more tank on let his aggression
bring him around
so again traps are things you land in
not things i put on
boom
you put it on
[Music]
anything that you have to turn
you have to be stronger than
and anything you have to be stronger
than
is not martial it is not aikido
keep going
[Music]
so you hear your right hand you push
down on it
[Music]
you're trying to do something to her
again you try to do something
hey
okay so first thing to understand is the
uh
nico mechanism is my two hands are close
not over here okay
my two hands are closed whether i'm
doing it this way or whether i'm doing
it this way or whether i'm doing it this
way
so these two hands
uh
are about maintaining the shape
okay so when i start to go like this
i have less control over the wrist and
the hand angle as they relate to each
other okay yeah it'll it'll get you pain
right but i really want the two hands
to work together okay
and to in this case in this technique
i
use
the reinforcement of the shape of the
technique by sealing up the back end
here
okay so all this is
not over here like this
now once i'm there i don't want to
push these what's happening to the shape
of your wall it's changing it's changing
do you see when i push you pull your
hand out forcefully down the bottom do
you think okay
i don't want that okay
and i don't want to turn this over
i turn it over your elbow's going to go
over the top you see yes i just keep
this shape okay you get it okay
so we're doing the technique
that's a weak center again and this is
not tension in the arm
you're coming up i put the shape on
there okay and now that's all i do i
just hold it in shape my elbow doesn't
need to be over this top my elbow does
not open my rib cage i'm just here
that's all i do do you feel anything
you can't stand up can you no try to
stand up you can't stand up okay so you
want to grab can you move in no no you
can't move it okay where's the in space
and look you got a little that's the
trick you go into the in space and now
you're downward pressure you see without
me shoving it down
i'm doing the same thing
boom
and that's a bracing angle on that elbow
oh
disconnect your center you're coming up
i feel that pressure i'm going to let it
go
come right to here hi do you see let
your aggression do your thing
and you got it do you feel it you get
into it i don't shove it down
i don't crank it around you did it okay
and now i have sequentially lowered your
standing position i am increasing your
position at disadvantage do you see
go back where you were
you were up
do you see oh you come around i take oh
you're down and now you're this much
lower
okay or the break in your case as you
disconnect
okay
i'm gonna release you
okay i'm not gonna panic by you when i
feel this being compromised
i let it go go and i come to here and i
just wait
okay